i did want to ask you about her accent
so is that something that you were
preparing to embrace for the character's
full run
and if that was the case i guess is it a
bummer to work on something like that
only to
have to lose it after putting all that
work into it
so the sokovian accent was created by
me and aaron and our dialect coach
because it's a fake country and we could
find different
sources of slavic sounds and we want to
make sure it didn't sound russian
because um because black widow speaks
russian
and so we just needed to sound more like
slovakian
and um so he created these sound changes
that worked for aaron's british accent
going to slovakia basically in my
american accent so that we sounded
related
and then all of a sudden all these other
characters had to speak in
different films um so the sokovian
accent took a lot of time and i and i
um it's not hasn't gone anywhere it has
lightened up because she moved to i mean
everything's been very like
you know there have been reasons for
everything it lightened up when she
started living in the states
and in one division she is playing the
role
of being in an american sitcom
and so it's she we haven't
got it's not gone okay
it is it is it is it is absolutely
still there